I am done some sad news this evening for
us here at the five and at the Fox News
Channel
today we are all mourning the loss of
one of our crew members yesterday our
video operator Brian sterling passed
away Brian was a vital part of the Fox
News team working at the channel for
eight years and on this show for the
majority of his tenure he had a
wonderful demeanor and was always
someone who had a smile on his face you
couldn't have known a nicer man he
leaves behind a wife his 13 year old son
and a 16 year old daughter they are in
our thoughts and in our prayers
Brian was loved by everyone and he will
be greatly missed my heart goes out to
the family and to the children I know
what it's like I lost my mother when I
was 10 and people really came together
to make donations to help our family for
my brother and I and I know the Fox News
Channel is doing that for Brian and his
family yeah it was a shock he so young
Dean well our deepest condolences to
their family and we will certainly be
participating in the fund for the kids